estoy trabajando el repartidor cuando yo
debería ser ingeniero rafael encontró un
trabajo alternativo mientras que espera
la homologación de su diploma chileno
por el estado español no me deja hacer
nada
por lo tanto claro no me queda otra que
ir agarrando lo que me vaya saliendo
empezó hace diez meses los trámites pero
aún le queda mucho para ejercer
considerando los testimonios de otras
personas que han hecho un procedimiento
algunos ha dilatado hasta tres años como
el 15 mil personas están esperando una
homologación de título de la mano de
azua que ve muy bien frente al problema
el gobierno prepara un decreto para
acortar el proceso pasará de durar dos
años a seis meses como lo explica este
senador las comunicaciones van a ser
telemática ya no va haber comunicaciones
por correo ordinario y además los
solicitantes van a poder acceder también
telemáticamente a su expediente y saber
en qué situación está de tal forma que
en todo momento tengan información de
cómo está su expediente y qué tiempo le
queda para resolverse una reforma
necesaria según esos médicos colombianos
nuestros diplomas no tienen valor para
españa'
jaime ya lleva dos años esperando su
homologación esa burocracia hace que
muchas veces nos sintamos abrumados por
el hecho de tener que hacer tantos
trámites
tantas llamadas para solamente digamos
habilitar el título la situación les
parece injusta a los médicos que han
trabajado de voluntarios durante el
confinamiento como jose
el pico de la pandemia tuvieron digamos
su mano de obra que no les estuvo a
coste cero y posteridad de eso no no no
hubo ningún beneficio en contraposición
para nosotros que ayudamos ahora esperan
beneficiar del decreto gubernamental que
estará aprobado al final del año